so there was a press release put out
recently uh titled mathematical model
predicts best way to build muscle
um which you know that's that's
obviously a very audacious title uh
that's that's gonna suck you right in um
and this uh
press release and the paper underlying
it uh generated enough interest that it
actually batted for the cycle when it
came to
people reaching out to me on every
platform that i can be reached on uh
people posted about this in our facebook
groups they posted about it in the
subreddit they messaged it to me on
facebook they emailed it to me and they
hit me up about it in my instagram inbox
uh so
and and i believe it was different
people every time so
clearly clearly there's general interest
in this
uh
and a lot of people uh who want my take
so i will oblige them
so anyway um like i said the the title
of the press releases mechanical model
or mathematical model predicts best way
to build muscle uh the study underlying
it is titled why exercise builds muscles
titan mechanosensing control skeletal
muscle growth under load
and a lot of the focus on this came from
one key quote from the press release
the quote was and this is from one of
the authors our model offers a
physiological basis for the idea that
muscle growth mainly occurs at 70
percent of maximum load which is the
idea behind resistance training said
terentagev
below that the opening rate of titan
kinase drops precipitously and precludes
mechanosensitive signaling from taking
place above that rapid exhaustion
prevents a good outcome which our model
has uh quantitatively predicted
so anyway i i think the reason that this
generated a lot of buzz
is because you have these people doing
like to be clear super nerd level
research uh
seeming to validate what the bros have
been saying for a long time 70 1rm uh
that's around a 12 rep max load for most
exercises uh and it's you know something
you'd probably be doing for sets of 10
if you're trying to hit failure in about
three four five sets something you'd be
doing for about sets of eight if you
were trained with a few reps left in
reserve so like 70 1rm is like probably
the single percentage
most associated with like the 8 to 12
rep range which is the classical
hypertrophy range and so uh yeah it's a
three rep max for me
yeah that's fair
uh
do do you mind if i
break subject confidentiality
for my knowledge
uh yeah so so this [ __ ] right
here had the worst bench press strength
endurance of anyone in my thesis study
uh trucks was a subject the the total
number of reps
completed in a single set to failure at
75 1rm
uh it ranged from 6 to 15 and uh
you were the six yep
mr six
the six god as they say
um
anyway so uh
see i think that's one of the reasons it
generated so much interest you have very
very technical research
seeming to confirm what people have been
saying like quote unquote in the
trenches for a long time
uh that that confluence of events seems
very satisfying and so uh i think a lot
of people were interested in that
and i think a lot of people
specifically
wanted my take on it because
i've been saying for for years now that
you know really the the hypertrophy
range probably isn't as narrow as folks
have been saying um on a per set basis
as long as you're getting pretty close
to failure
anywhere from sets of 20 25 reps on the
light end of things to sets of
probably around five or six reps on the
heavy end of things all seem to promote
hypertrophy
uh pretty much equally well on a per set
basis
um
so anyway i since i've been saying that
i think people were interested in in my
take on this and um
anyway the paper did not at all find
that uh
70 of 1rm is the ideal load for
hypertrophy
uh but before we can get into that it's
it's worth some background to talk about
what the paper
was actually interested in looking at
uh so just as background uh it's
commonly believed i wouldn't say even
commonly believed it's nearly
universally believed
that one of the main precipitators of
hypertrophy signaling is something
called mechanotransduction
so mechanotransduction is basically the
idea that there are proteins uh within
or surrounding your muscle fibers that
can sense in increase in force being
created by or transmitted through the
muscle
and then once that force is sensed that
kicks off a signaling cascade that
eventually results in increases in
muscle protein synthesis so that's
mechanotransduction
uh and that like i said that's
almost universally believed to be
either the main or one of the main
initiators of hypertrophy there's some
protein somewhere or multiple proteins
multiple places within your muscles that
are accomplishing mechanotransduction
and that kicks off all of the things
that eventually result in muscle protein
synthesis
and there are several candidate proteins
that might be the main quote-unquote
main
sensor for mechanotransduction
and what the authors of this paper
basically wanted to put forth
is that there is a possible candidate uh
for the main or or being one of the main
mechano transduct
transducers that is maybe not discussed
as often as it should be
so that's referred to as the kinase
domain of titan there are other
potential candidates for
mechanotransduction probably most
notably focal adhesion kinase
that kind of get a lot of press in the
mechanistic like hypertrophy signaling
world
and these these authors are basically
arguing that the kinase domain of titan
should be getting
a similar amount of attention because
they think that might be one of the main
mechano-trans transducers
um
so what they did
is they generated a pretty intricate
model to essentially predict okay what
would acute and chronic responses to
resistance training look like
if we assume that this particular kinase
is the most important
cytomechanotransduction so
if we assume that this particular region
on the titan protein is your main
mechanotransducer
what would that predict uh and so they
they generated
uh
i have to give them props for this the
model they generated was ridiculous like
they accounted for so many variables uh
like when they were modeling the effects
of load on like how long this particular
kinase would be open and active they
even modeled like
the impact i believe of
fiber size on ribosome density within
the fiber and rates of atp usage at
different levels of uh
of contraction strength like there was
there was a
they weren't lazy with model
construction like they accounted for
just about every variable that they
realistically could have um but like it
did still rest on a lot of assumptions
the main assumption being
it's not proven that this particular
titan-associated kinase is the main
mechano transducer it was basically
assuming
grant us that it is if it is then then
what could we predict
um
and so basically the predictions they
generated from this model were
uh
physiologically plausible and more or
less in line with experimental outcomes
uh so basically the the biggest thing
they were putting forth in their
research is like hey
if we assume that this is the main
mechano transducer we can generate
predictions
that look pretty much like the real
world
therefore
this might be the main mechano
transducer therefore
more research is warranted to see if
that's the case so so that's that's
basically what what they were doing this
was uh
more or less a very very
elaborate hypothesis generating model um
to to put forth
theoretical evidence to suggest that
this particular titan-associated kinase
deserves more actual experimental
research to see if it is as important as
these researchers think it might be like
that that was the main point of the
paper um
so
the big question is this evidence that
70 percent of 1rm is the optimal
intensity for building muscle
no it's not
again the main problem the authors were
addressing is that there's not enough
research on this particular kinase in
the first place
so this paper i would say is basically
two steps away from
constituting
evidence that we could use to inform
training prescription
so
this was basically to generate
hypotheses for in vitro research or
animal research and then if they do that
research and it pans out then it'll be
time for human research and probably
three steps away from actual
uh
implementation because then when you get
to human research then it's going to be
mechanistic work acute work and then
maybe longitudinal work to look at
further implications of this
so we're we're talking about
a pretty long
research process potentially leading
from this paper to
novel and useful insights about how to
to program training but that's where
things stand now
it's
very very intricate very very cool
modeling work
uh
but if you looked at the press release
and you're counting it as
definitive evidence that seventy percent
one rm is
for sure the optimal intensity to train
at uh we're
years potentially decades away from
being able to uh
make any sort of statement like that
grounded on
this research as it stands today yeah
the press releases were hilarious the
headlines were like
trainers hate these scientists for
exposing the real keys to muscle gain
yeah it's just not
not what they were doing correct
okay um
let's see one of the other things i was
going to talk about is uh
a study that we recently posted about on
instagram so i'm going to skip that one
and just say
follow stronger by science on instagram
uh
if you scroll back probably probably i
would say six posts by the time that
this episode is coming out uh you'll see
one with a scatter plot on it uh that
has to do with squatting and ankle
mobility check out that post i i was
basically just going to talk about the
same the same stuff we posted
uh just double dipping a little bit but
anyway i'll skip that one
uh so let's talk about caffeine
caffeine's good stuff if you're
following along on video i've got my
coffee uh
i like caffeine it's nice
and uh caffeine is also for the ladies
and that's what we're talking about here
so there was a meta-analysis that came
out a couple years or not a couple years
a couple uh months ago
titled ergogenic effects of acute
caffeine intake on muscular endurance
and muscular strength in women a
meta-analysis
by gurgic and del coso
um
and and this this was i would say an
important meta-analysis
because uh you know we've talked about
how caffeine is a useful ergogenic for
increasing force output and increasing
strength endurance
on the podcast several times
um
and i think we have touched on
uh sex differences in caffeine
metabolism um but but there's there was
some degree of trepidation
uh
certainly within my brain and also
within the research community about
whether or not
research on the ergogenic effects of
caffeine generalized from males to
females
there were a couple reasons for that
first off
a couple of the early papers
looking at
the the potential ergogenic effects of
caffeine
in women failed to find significant
effects whereas similarly design studies
did find significant effects in males
so there were some early suggestions
that maybe caffeine
was ergogenic in males but not females
secondly it's known that
estrogen affects caffeine metabolism um
specifically it affects the functioning
of the cyp182 gene which is
or the cyp182 enzyme which is the rate
limiting enzyme and caffeine metabolism
um that carries the load for like 95
percent of caffeine metabolism yeah yeah
yeah um
so you know uh and
there are also some suggestions that say
cyp182 gene variants might affect
uh caffeine metabo well they certainly
affect caffeine metabolism and
potentially therefore the ergogenic
effects of caffeine although that's not
quite as clear so you know maybe if if
there's a hormone that's affecting
caffeine metabolism that could affect
the ergogenic effects uh differently in
males versus females uh
and also
some degree of trepidation just related
to the fact that there was
there was very little research
uh looking at the potential ergogenic
effects of caffeine in women so just to
illustrate uh there was a
2020
meta-analysis
looking at the impact of caffeine on
strength and strength endurance uh this
was not a meta-analysis that
specifically
uh restricted
i was checking her real quick to see if
you were an author on it you were not
when was uh when was the meta on
caffeine that you were a co-author on
is that like 2018 2019 something like
that the years all blend together yeah
whatever um so
so yeah the the most recent
meta-analysis looking at the general
ergogenic effects of caffeine on
resistance training acute outcomes uh
was was published in 2020
it didn't restrict the subjects to
only males but 19 studies were included
and of the 19 studies 15 used
exclusively male subjects
two used mixed sex cohorts that were
still very strongly slanted towards male
subjects so
one had 11 total subjects including nine
males and two females
one had 17 total subjects with 13 males
and four females and of the 19 studies
only two used exclusively female
subjects
um so you know we're we're talking about
theoretically uh
uh
a meta-analysis on the effects of
caffeine
independent of sex but functionally it
was a meta-analysis on the impact of
caffeine in males because males
accounted for 87 of the subjects in the
studies included in that meta um so even
relative to exercise science generally
the caffeine research was very very
slanted towards having male subjects
there's a 2014 paper that that people
bring up a lot
showing that in exercise and sports
science research about sixty percent of
the subjects are male about forty
percent female
um so when you're looking at eighty
seven male subjects in a particular body
of research you're
you're really dealing with a body of
research where um
you know
the the potential impact of what
whatever you're studying on
women and females is uh
is very underrepresented in in the body
of literature as it stands
so anyway that was the state of of the
research in 2020 um
but since then there's been a uh
explosion of sorts in caffeine research
in women so in in the meta-analysis i'm
going to be talking about here very
briefly uh there were eight studies
included looking at the impacts of
caffeine versus placebo on
one rm strength and measures of strength
endurance
and of the eight studies included five
of them were published in either 2020 or
2021
so
a majority of
the research looking at the effects of
caffeine on resistance training outcomes
in women has been published in the last
year uh and with that in mind
uh yeah they performed
a competent meta-analysis looking at the
effects on 1rm strength and strength
endurance
and found that caffeine has a small
positive effect on 1rm strength and
strength endurance
in women
and the effect size estimates uh from
this meta-analysis were virtually
identical to the effect size estimates
uh observed in the
prior meta-analysis i mentioned that
came out in 2020 and basically included
all male subjects
so
currently at this point it seems that
caffeine
is also ergogenic in women and is
similarly the ergogenic effects are uh
pretty similar uh regardless of sex so
uh that's where that's where the
research stands currently and uh
i gotta i gotta i got
can't talk i gotta be honest it was nice
uh
seeing how many more studies in the area
have been published in the last year for
for us to be able to uh
see a meta-analysis on it and uh
be able to make that comparison
yeah it's cool because uh you know i see
del coso
uh in the outline here i it was a few
years back i i think his group published
a paper
and the entire purpose of the paper was
to bring awareness to the fact that was
like hey there's a huge absence of
caffeine research in women
and so it looks like people saw that
paper and said yep we got it took that
directive and now we're starting to see
some of that research finding its way
into journals and you got to understand
that there's going to be a lag time
there usually of at least one to two
years but often longer when you know
from the time a research idea is formed
and then the study gets planned ethics
approval recruitment data collection
writing rejection rejection rejection
yeah i mean yeah and it can be several
years so i think we're starting to see
uh you know some of the uh fruits of
that labor when it comes to bringing
awareness to uh
why is that funny no i i was just
thinking you know of other times that's
happened um
probably the big the biggest example i
can think of is uh
and this kind of circles back to
the first uh paper i talked about the
modeling paper from from the research
roundup uh
the uh low load versus moderate load
hypertrophy research uh there was that
paper by
by mitchell
i think in 2013 2014 which was just
looking at unilateral knee extensions 80
versus 30
finding pretty similar hypertrophy which
at the time was was a pretty novel
finding
and then
uh
like you said takes about two years to
get new studies out
you could have set a clock from the time
that mitchell paper was published two
years later there was a deluge of like
a dozen studies coming out over the span
of about 18 months
largely confirming those findings but uh
but yeah i mean there there was a very
influential paper
about a year two years of flag time and
then boom everybody uh everybody starts
getting in on it
yeah which which is exactly how it
should work correct
a lot of times you'll see people who
have an idea that they're very fond of
and they'll say but there is evidence
for this and they'll show you one paper
with like 24 participants and you're
like
let's wait until that next wave of eight
or ten
other papers comes out and see if we can
you know figure out the pattern there
yeah so
uh it's good to see for sure i get
nervous anytime i say something
especially if it's a saying or a phrase
and you start laughing
because like
i
i don't read and i don't
consume
really any type of content and so i
don't know how people speak these days i
feel like i'm always like walking into
some kind of linguistic trap whenever
that happens but i'm glad to see that
you were just thinking of something else
um no whenever uh
i think my knee jerk responds to just
about anything that happens in my brain
is to giggle yeah that's good it's fine